the reason you tell stories is so that
we can learn to be the hero of our own
lives then any obstacle that you face
you decide what part of the story we're
in yet you know we are you in the same
way that you write what your characters
are going to do and how your characters
are going to react you can do that for
yourself you can you can have a really
crappy meeting with the studio executive
and you can either choose to say see I
wasn't meant to do this or oh this is
the moment where the hero decides
they're gonna learn how to pitch and
they have a goal and they they go off
and find friends and mentors and but
know very well there'll be more twists
and turns coming but that's part of the
fun of the journey so it's kind of like
it's appreciating this - the story would
be no fun if there weren't twists and
turns it's so much more fun to get your
goal if it looked like you never were
gonna get it the joy is so much sweeter
on the other side of that and so if you
have a really huge disappointment you
should just know that when you do win
it's gonna feel so good
you